as I expressed earlier.
So I think you can come to the table, both being passionate about something.
So at least you care.
And I would like to believe -- the c-word has also become
a horrible word -- "compromise," right?
So you have the far left and the far right,
and compromise -- forget it.
Those groups don't want to even think about it.
But you have a huge swath of voters, myself included,
who are registered independents,
like 40 percent of us, right?
So there is a huge faction of America that wants to see change
and wants to see people come together.
It's just that we have to figure out
how to do that.
CA: So let's talk about that for a minute,
because we're having these TED Dialogues, we're trying to bridge.
There's a lot of people out there, right now, perhaps especially on the left,
who think this is a terrible idea,
that actually, the only moral response to the great tyranny
that may be about to emerge in America
is to resist it at every stage, is to fight it tooth and nail,
it's a mistake to try and do this.
Just fight!
Is there a case for that?
DB: It depends what "fight" means. If it means literal fighting, then no.
If it means marching, well maybe marching to raise consciousness,
that seems fine.
But if you want change in this country, we do it through parties and politics.
We organize parties, and those parties are big, diverse, messy coalitions,
and we engage in politics,
and politics is always morally unsatisfying
because it's always a bunch of compromises.
But politics is essentially a competition between partial truths.
The Trump people have a piece of the truth in America.
I think Trump himself is the wrong answer to the right question,
but they have some truth,
and it's truth found in the epidemic of opiates around the country,
it's truth found in the spread of loneliness,
it's the truth found in people whose lives are inverted.
They peaked professionally at age 30,
and it's all been downhill since.
And so, understanding that doesn't take fighting,
it takes conversation and then asking,
"What are we going to replace Trump with?"
GC: But you saw fighting last night, even at the speech,
because you saw the Democratic women who came and wore white
to honor the suffragette movement.
I remember back during the campaign
where some Trump supporters wanted to actually get rid of the amendment
that allowed us to vote as women.
It was like, what?
So I don't know if that's the right way to fight.
It was interesting, because I was looking in the audience,
trying to see Democratic women who didn't wear white.
So there's a lot going on there,
and there's a lot of ways to fight that are not necessarily doing that.
CA: I mean, one of the key questions, to me, is:
The people who voted for Trump but, if you like, are more in the center,
like they're possibly amenable to persuasion --
are they more likely to be persuaded by seeing a passionate uprising
of people saying, "No, no, no, you can't!"
or will that actually piss them off and push them away?
DB: How are any of us persuaded?
Am I going to persuade you by saying, "Well, you're kind of a bigot,
you're supporting bigotry, you're supporting sexism.
You're a primitive, fascistic rise from some authoritarian past"?
That's probably not going to be too persuasive to you.
And so the way any of us are persuaded is by:
a) some basic show of respect for the point of view, and saying,
"I think this guy is not going to get you where you need to go."
And there are two phrases you've heard over and over again,
wherever you go in the country.
One, the phrase "flyover country."
And that's been heard for years,
but I would say this year, I heard it almost on an hourly basis,
a sense of feeling invisible.
And then the sense a sense of the phrase "political correctness."
Just that rebellion: "They're not even letting us say what we think."
And I teach at Yale.
The narrowing of debate is real.
CA: So you would say this is a trap that liberals have fallen into
by celebrating causes they really believe in,
often expressed through the language of "political correctness."
They have done damage. They have pushed people away.
DB: I would say a lot of the argument, though,
with "descent to fascism," "authoritarianism" --
that just feels over-the-top to people.
And listen, I've written eight million anti-Trump columns,
but it is a problem, especially for the coastal media,
that every time he does something slightly wrong, we go to 11,
and we're at 11 every day.
And it just strains credibility at some point.
CA: Crying wolf a little too loud and a little too early.
But there may be a time when we really do have to cry wolf.
GC: But see -- one of the most important things to me
is how the conservative media handles Trump.
Will they call him out when things are not true,
or will they just go along with it?
To me, that is what is essential in this entire discussion,
because when you have followers of somebody
who don't really care if he tells the truth or not,
that can be very dangerous.
So to me, it's: How is the conservative media going to respond to it?
I mean, you've been calling them out.
But how will other forms of conservative media deal with that
as we move forward?
DB: It's all shifted, though.
The conservative media used to be Fox or Charles Krauthammer or George Will.
They're no longer the conservative media.
Now there's another whole set of institutions further right,
which is Breitbart and Infowars, Alex Jones, Laura Ingraham,
and so they're the ones who are now his base, not even so much Fox.
CA: My last question for the time being is just on this question of the truth.
I mean, it's one of the scariest things to people right now,
that there is no agreement, nationally, on what is true.
I've never seen anything like it,
where facts are so massively disputed.
Your whole newspaper, sir, is delivering fake news every day.
DB: And failing.
(Laughter)
CA: And failing. My commiserations.
But is there any path
whereby we can start to get some kind of consensus,
to believe the same things?
Can online communities play a role here?
How do we fix this?
GC: See, I understand how that happened.
That's another groundswell kind of emotion
that was going on in the middle of America
and not being heard,
in thinking that the mainstream media was biased.
There's a difference, though, between being biased and being fake.
To me, that is a very important distinction in this conversation.
So let's just say that there was some bias in the mainstream media.
OK. So there are ways to try and mend that.
But what Trump's doing is nuclearizing that and saying,
"Look, we're just going to call all of that fake."
That's where it gets dangerous.
CA: Do you think enough of his supporters
have a greater loyalty to the truth than to any ...
Like, the principle of not supporting something
that is demonstrably not true
actually matters, so there will be a correction at some point?
DB: I think the truth eventually comes out.
So for example, Donald Trump has based a lot of his economic policy
on this supposition that Americans have lost manufacturing jobs
because they've been stolen by the Chinese.
That is maybe 13 percent of the jobs that left.
The truth is that 87 percent of the jobs were replaced by technology.
That is just the truth.
And so as a result, when he says,
"I'm going to close TPP and all the jobs will come roaring back,"
they will not come roaring back.
So that is an actual fact, in my belief.
And --
(Laughter)
GC: But I'm saying what his supporters think is the truth,
no matter how many times you might say that,
they still believe him.
DB: But eventually either jobs will come back or they will not come back,
and at that point, either something will work or it doesn't work,
and it doesn't work or not work because of great marketing,
it works because it actually addresses a real problem
and so I happen to think the truth will out.
CA: If you've got a question, please raise your hand here.
Yael Eisenstat: I'll speak into the box.
My name's Yael Eisenstat.
I hear a lot of this talk
about how we all need to start talking to each other more
and understanding each other more,
and I've even written about this, published on this subject as well,
but now today I keep hearing liberals -- yes, I live in New York,
I can be considered a liberal --
we sit here and self-analyze:
What did we do to not understand the Rust Belt?
Or: What can we do to understand Middle America better?
And what I'd like to know:
Have you seen any attempts or conversations from Middle America
of what can I do to understand the so-called coastal elites better?
Because I'm just offended as being put in a box as a coastal elite
as someone in Middle America is as being considered a flyover state
and not listened to.
CA: There you go, I can hear Facebook cheering as you --
(Laughter)
DB: I would say -- and this is someone who has been conservative
all my adult life --
when you grow up conservative,
you learn to speak both languages.
Because if I'm going to listen to music,
I'm not going to listen to Ted Nugent.
So a lot of my favorite rock bands are all on the left.
If I'm going to go to a school,
I'm going probably to school where the culture is liberal.
If I'm going to watch a sitcom
or a late-night comedy show, it's going to be liberal.
If I'm going to read a good newspaper, it'll be the New York Times.
As a result, you learn to speak both languages.
And that actually, at least for a number of years,
when I started at National Review with William F. Buckley,
it made us sharper,
because we were used to arguing against people every day.
The problem now that's happened is you have ghettoization on the right
and you can live entirely in rightworld,
so as a result, the quality of argument on the right has diminished,
because you're not in the other side
all the time.
But I do think if you're living in Minnesota or Iowa or Arizona,
the coastal elites make themselves aware to you,
so you know that language as well,
but it's not the reverse.
CA: But what does Middle America not get about coastal elites?
So the critique is,
you are not dealing with the real problems.
There's a feeling of a snobbishness, an elitism that is very off-putting.
What are they missing?
If you could plant one piece of truth
from the mindset of someone in this room, for example,
what would you say to them?
DB: Just how insanely wonderful we are.
(Laughter)
No, I reject the category.
The problem with populism is the same problem with elitism.
It's just a prejudice on the basis
of probably an over-generalized social class distinction
which is too simplistic to apply in reality.
Those of us in New York know there are some people in New York
who are completely awesome, and some people who are pathetic,
and if you live in Iowa, some people are awesome and some people are pathetic.
It's not a question of what degree you have
or where you happen to live in the country.
The distinction is just a crude simplification to arouse political power.
GC: But I would encourage people to watch a television news show
or read a column that they normally wouldn't.
So if you are a Trump supporter, watch the other side for a day,
because you need to come out of the bubble
if you're ever going to have a conversation.
And both sides -- so if you're a liberal,
then watch something that's very conservative.
Read a column that is not something you would normally read,
because then you gain perspective of what the other side is thinking,
and to me, that's a start of coming together.
I worry about the same thing you worry about, these bubbles.
I think if you only watch certain entities,
you have no idea what the rest of the world is talking about.
DB: I think not only watching,
being part of an organization that meets at least once a month
that puts you in direct contact with people completely unlike yourself
is something we all have a responsibility for.
I may get this a little wrong,
but I think of the top-selling automotive models in this country,
I think the top three or four are all pickup trucks.
So ask yourself: How many people do I know who own a pickup truck?
And it could be very few or zero for a lot of people.
And that's sort of a warning sign kind of a problem.
Where can I join a club
where I'll have a lot in common with a person who drives a pickup truck
because we have a common interest in whatever?
CA: And so the internet is definitely contributing to this.
A question here from Chris Ajemian:
"How do you feel structure of communications,
especially the prevalence of social media and individualized content,
can be used to bring together a political divide,
instead of just filing communities into echo chambers?"
I mean, it looks like Facebook and Google, since the election,
are working hard on this question.
They're trying to change the algorithms
so that they don't amplify fake news
to the extent that it happened last time round.
Do you see any other promising signs of ...?
GC: ... or amplify one side of the equation.
CA: Exactly.
GC: I think that was the constant argument from the right,
that social media and the internet in general
was putting articles towards the top that were not their worldview.
I think, again, that fed into the anger.
It fed into the anger of:
"You're pushing something that's not what I believe."
But social media has obviously changed everything,
and I think Trump is the example of Twitter changing absolutely everything.
And from his point of view,
he's reaching the American people without a filter,
which he believes the media is.
CA: Question from the audience.
Destiny: Hi. I'm Destiny.
I have a question regarding political correctness, and I'm curious:
When did political correctness become synonymous with silencing,
versus a way that we speak about other people
to show them respect and preserve their dignity?
GC: Well, I think the conservative media really pounded this issue
for the last 10 years.
I think that they really, really spent a lot of time
talking about political correctness,
and how people should have the ability to say what they think.
Another reason why Trump became so popular:
because he says what he thinks.
It also makes me think about the fact
that I do believe there are a lot of people in America
who agree with Steve Bannon,
but they would never say it publicly,
and so voting for Trump gave them the opportunity
to agree with it silently.
DB: On the issue of immigration, it's a legitimate point of view
that we have too many immigrants in the country,
that it's economically costly.
CA: That we have too many --
DB: Immigrants in the country, especially from Britain.
(Laughter)
GC: I kind of like the British accent, OK?
CA: I apologize. America, I am sorry.
(Laughter)
I'll go now.
DB: But it became sort of impermissible to say that,
because it was a sign that somehow you must be a bigot of some sort.
So the political correctness was not only cracking down on speech
that we would all find completely offensive,
it was cracking down on some speech that was legitimate,
and then it was turning speech and thought into action
and treating it as a crime,
and people getting fired and people thrown out of schools,
and there were speech codes written.
Now there are these diversity teams,
where if you say something that somebody finds offensive,
like, "Smoking is really dangerous," you can say "You're insulting my group,"
and the team from the administration will come down into your dorm room
and put thought police upon you.
And so there has been a genuine narrowing of what is permissible to say.
And some of it is legitimate.
There are certain words that there should be some social sanction against,
but some of it was used to enforce a political agenda.
CA: So is that a project
you would urge on liberals, if you like -- progressives --
to rethink the ground rules around political correctness
and accept a little more uncomfortable language
in certain circumstances?
Can you see that being solved
to an extent that others won't be so offended?
DB: I mean, most American universities, especially elite universities,
are overwhelmingly on the left,
and there's just an ease of temptation
to use your overwhelming cultural power to try to enforce some sort of thought
that you think is right and correct thought.
So, be a little more self-suspicious of, are we doing that?
And second, my university, the University of Chicago,
sent out this letter saying, we will have no safe spaces.
There will be no critique of micro-aggression.
If you get your feelings hurt, well, welcome to the world of education.
I do think that policy --
which is being embraced by a lot of people on the left, by the way --
is just a corrective to what's happened.
CA: So here's a question from Karen Holloway:
How do we foster an American culture
that's forward-looking, like Hamilton,
that expects and deals with change,
rather than wanting to have everything go back to some fictional past?
That's an easy question, right?
GC: Well, I'm still a believer in the American dream,
and I think what we can teach our children is the basics,
which is that hard work
and believing in yourself
in America, you can achieve whatever you want.
I was told that every single day.
When I got in the real world, I was like, wow, that's maybe not always so true.
But I still believe in that.
Maybe I'm being too optimistic.
So I still look towards the future for that to continue.
DB: I think you're being too optimistic.
GC: You do?
DB: The odds of an American young person exceeding their parents' salary --
a generation ago, like 86 percent did it.
Now 51 percent do it.
There's just been a problem in social mobility in the country.
CA: You've written that this entire century has basically been a disaster,
that the age of sunny growth is over and we're in deep trouble.
DB: Yeah, I mean, we averaged, in real terms, population-adjusted,
two or three percent growth for 50 years,
and now we've had less than one percent growth.
And so there's something seeping out.
And so if I'm going to tell people that they should take risks,
one of the things we're seeing is a rapid decline in mobility,
the number of people who are moving across state lines,
and that's especially true among millennials.
It's young people that are moving less.
So how do we give people the security from which they can take risk?
And I'm a big believer in attachment theory of raising children,
and attachment theory is based on the motto
that all of life is a series of daring adventures from a secure base.
Have you parents given you a secure base?
And as a society, we do not have a secure base,
and we won't get to that "Hamilton," risk-taking, energetic ethos
until we can supply a secure base.
CA: So I wonder whether there's ground here
to create almost like a shared agenda, a bridging conversation,
on the one hand recognizing that there is this really deep problem
that the system, the economic system that we built,
seems to be misfiring right now.
Second, that maybe, if you're right that it's not all about immigrants,
it's probably more about technology,
if you could win that argument,
that de-emphasizes what seems to me the single most divisive territory
between Trump supporters and others, which is around the role of the other.
It's very offensive to people on the left to have the other demonized
to the extent that the other seems to be demonized.
That feels deeply immoral,
and maybe people on the left could agree, as you said,
that immigration may have happened too fast,
and there is a limit beyond which human societies struggle,
but nonetheless this whole problem becomes de-emphasized
if automation is the key issue,
and then we try to work together on recognizing that it's real,
recognizing that the problem probably wasn't properly addressed
or seen or heard,
and try to figure out how to rebuild communities
using, well, using what?
That seems to me to become the fertile conversation of the future:
How do we rebuild communities in this modern age,
with technology doing what it's doing,
and reimagine this bright future?
GC: That's why I go back to optimism.
I'm not being ... it's not like I'm not looking at the facts,
where we've come or where we've come from.
But for gosh sakes, if we don't look at it from an optimistic point of view --
I'm refusing to do that just yet.
I'm not raising my 12- and 13-year-old to say, "Look, the world is dim."
CA; We're going to have one more question from the room here.
Questioner: Hi. Hello. Sorry.
You both mentioned the infrastructure plan and Russia
and some other things that wouldn't be traditional Republican priorities.
What do you think, or when, will Republicans be motivated
to take a stand against Trumpism?
GC: After last night, not for a while.
He changed a lot last night, I believe.
DB: His popularity among Republicans -- he's got 85 percent approval,
which is higher than Reagan had at this time,
and that's because society has just gotten more polarized.
So people follow the party much more than they used to.
So if you're waiting for Paul Ryan and the Republicans in Congress
to flake away,
it's going to take a little while.
GC: But also because they're all concerned about reelection,
and Trump has so much power with getting people either for you
or against you,
and so, they're vacillating every day, probably:
"Well, should I go against or should I not?"
But last night, where he finally sounded presidential,
I think most Republicans are breathing a sigh of relief today.
DB: The half-life of that is short.
GC: Right -- I was just going to say, until Twitter happens again.
CA: OK, I want to give each of you the chance
to imagine you're speaking to -- I don't know --
the people online who are watching this,
who may be Trump supporters,
who may be on the left, somewhere in the middle.
How would you advise them to bridge or to relate to other people?
Can you share any final wisdom on this?
Or if you think that they shouldn't, tell them that as well.
GC: I would just start by saying
that I really think any change and coming together starts from the top,
just like any other organization.
And I would love if, somehow,
Trump supporters or people on the left could encourage their leaders
to show that compassion from the top,
because imagine the change that we could have
if Donald Trump tweeted out today,
to all of his supporters,
"Let's not be vile anymore to each other.
Let's have more understanding.
As a leader, I'm going to be more inclusive
to all of the people of America."
To me, it starts at the top.
Is he going to do that? I have no idea.
But I think that everything starts from the top,
and the power that he has
in encouraging his supporters
to have an understanding of where people are coming from on the other side.
CA: David. DB: Yeah, I guess I would say
I don't think we can teach each other to be civil,
and give us sermons on civility.
That's not going to do it.
It's substance and how we act,
and the nice thing about Donald Trump is he smashed our categories.
All the categories that we thought we were thinking in, they're obsolete.
They were great for the 20th century. They're not good for today.
He's got an agenda which is about closing borders and closing trade.
I just don't think it's going to work.
I think if we want to rebuild communities, recreate jobs,
we need a different set of agenda
that smashes through all our current divisions and our current categories.
For me, that agenda is Reaganism on macroeconomic policy,
Sweden on welfare policy
and cuts across right and left.
I think we have to have a dynamic economy that creates growth.
That's the Reagan on economic policy.
But people have to have that secure base.
There have to be nurse-family partnerships;
there has to be universal preschool;
there have to be charter schools;
there have to be college programs with wraparound programs
for parents and communities.
We need to help heal the crisis of social solidarity in this country
and help heal families,
and government just has to get a lot more involved
in the way liberals like to rebuild communities.
At the other hand, we have to have an economy that's free and open
the way conservatives used to like.
And so getting the substance right is how you smash through
the partisan identities,
because the substance is what ultimately shapes our polarization.
CA: David and Gretchen, thank you so much
for an absolutely fascinating conversation.
Thank you. That was really, really interesting.
(Applause)
Hey, let's keep the conversation going.
We're continuing to try and figure out
whether we can add something here,
so keep the conversation going on Facebook.
Give us your thoughts from whatever part of the political spectrum you're on,
and actually, wherever in the world you are.
This is not just about America. It's about the world, too.
But we're not going to end today without music,
because if we put music in every political conversation,
the world would be completely different, frankly.
It just would.
(Applause)
Up in Harlem, this extraordinary woman,
Vy Higginsen, who's actually right here --
let's get a shot of her.
(Applause)
She created this program that brings teens together,
teaches them the joy and the impact of gospel music,
and hundreds of teens have gone through this program.
It's transformative for them.
The music they made, as you already heard,
is extraordinary,
and I can't think of a better way of ending this TED Dialogue
than welcoming Vy Higginsen's Gospel Choir from Harlem.
Thank you.
(Applause)
(Singing) Choir: O beautiful for spacious skies
For amber waves of grain
For purple mountain majesties
Above the fruited plain
America!
God shed his grace on thee
And crown thy good with brotherhood
From sea to shining sea
(Applause)